[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis weil
es gerade jetzt in der kalten jahreszeit
liebe ich hefegebäck ok hefegebäck geht
bei mir das ganze jahr über
aber jetzt mache ich einen kasten kuchen
einen hefezopf kasten kuchen mit feigen
und wann müssen und das wird dann wie so
eine art spirale und das ganze ist nur
mit spekulatius gewürzt wird richtig
lecker zuerst stelle ich mal den
hefeteig kern für den hefeteig habe ich
hier schon die zutaten ich brauche dafür
nämlich 30 gramm wasser ein würfel hefe
60 g zucker 2 etwas orangen passte einen
teelöffel salz 220 gramm milch 500 gramm
mehl und 120 gramm weiche butter zuerst
verrühren ich jetzt das wasser mit der
hefe als die die wir jetzt hier so rein
geprügelt machen wir wie so eine art
vorteig und dann zu etwa die hälfte des
zuckers mit rein kurz verrühren
das lasse ich jetzt etwa 15 minuten auf
gehen und dadurch dass wir jetzt diese
15 minuten nehme geht später der
hefeteig auch noch schneller auf und er
wird sogar feinporigen ihr könnt es
jetzt entweder kurz abdecken und bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen oder im
dampf backofen oder im warmen backofen
bei etwa 30 grad ich mache das jetzt
einfach hier bei der geher stufe dann
geht es nämlich noch schneller
so sieht das hefe wasser jetzt aus und
jetzt kann ich im prinzip alle zutaten
miteinander verrühren
also kommt jetzt hier alles in der
küchenmaschine ihr könnt den teig aber
natürlich auch einfach mit der hand
verkehr hier noch der rest zucker rein
die milch könnt ihr übrigens auch ein
bisschen erwärmen
falls ja aus dem kühlschrank kommen
sollte
[Musik]
es geht auch bei induktion echte immer
super schnell dann kommen hier die
eigelbe noch mit rein hoch das einen
quest weil das so schön und dann hängt
dann wird es ein grillfest ein bisschen
orangen passte das hat er gleich ein
schönes orangenaroma im hefeteig und
dann noch salz und zum schluss kommt
noch die mutter mit rein und die gebe
ich einfach in kleinen stückchen dazu
und wenn ihr den teig jetzt mit der hand
kneten solltet dann macht es wirklich
für fünf bis zehn minuten dass er schön
geschmeidig wird
[Musik]
für die füllung nämlich 50 g butter 100
gramm walnüsse zwei teelöffel
spekulatius gewürz 60 gramm brauner
zucker 150 gramm zeigen die sind
getrocknet und zwei weiß der muss ab 70
grad noch sein café nichts zu tun so
oder so kommt die post kann demokraten
kaffee machen
der teig sind jetzt perfekt aus ergänzt
schön ist geschmeidig und ihr seht da
klebt auch nicht mehr
jetzt könnt ihr ihn so mit der hand kurz
zu einer kugel zusammen formen und dann
die schüssel ein bisschen fetten mit
bakterien spray damit der teig nicht an
klebt die oberfläche auch ein bisschen
fetten so trocknet er nämlich beim
aufgehen nicht aus und jetzt deckt ihren
ab und lasst den für etwa eine halbe
stunde bis stunde auf gehen bei
raumtemperatur im warmen backofen oder
wieder bei der stufe und ich mache das
jetzt dabei der stufe weil es eben
einfach viel zeit spart und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
füllung machen
daher stufe 30 grad 30 oder 35 geht
beides
es werden die walnüsse zerkleinert wie
können sie entweder fein hacken oder
kurz zu zerkleinern
und ihr könnt sie gerne so ein bisschen
grob landen
das mag ich ganz gerne in so einem zopf
dann sind die feigen dran
[Musik]
und hier gebe ich jetzt damit etwas
einfacher geht das eiweiß macht dazu und
direkt auch den zucker
jetzt noch ein bisschen spekulatius
gewürz findet das nicht mögt ihr
lebkuchengewürz oder einfach nur zimt
und dann noch die weiche butter und
jetzt lasse ich das alles hier stehen
für reese war noch kurz und warb einfach
kurz auf den hefeteig
[Musik]
der teig ist wunderbar aufgegangen
es geht doch welches ratzfatz ich hatte
ja eigentlich überlegt einen kasten
wochen zu machen
deswegen habe ich auch euch begrüßt mit
kasten kuchen und das wollte ich hier in
der glasbau machen darin funktioniert
ist echt super und vor allem es brennt
auch nichts an
jetzt habe ich mir aber gedacht nähe
kommen doch kein kasten kuchen
wir machen einen guglhupf deswegen habe
ich jetzt hier der block form und habe
hier auch schon etwas butter geschmolzen
ich nehme jetzt butter zum fetten jetzt
hier mit diego gelobt form einfetten
damit ich diesen guter geschmack mit
drin
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den teig auf etwas mehl
ausrollen
ich liebe einfach hier beträgt ja ich
glaube hier verträgt was mein
lieblingsteil vor schönweiß jetzt einen
großen rechteck ausrollen das rechteck
er in die länge ausrollen nicht in die
breite und winke ich diese 60 zentimeter
matte ausnutzen
da kommt jetzt diese füllung drauf wenn
ihr merkt diesen bisschen fest geworden
durchstehen packt einfach zwei drei
esslöffel wasser mit rein das mache ich
kurz
jetzt am besten mit einer palette kurz
verteilen
[Musik]
und jetzt bei der kugelform ganz wichtig
mit der nacht nach oben in die kugelform
legen dann später wieder der kuchen raus
gestürzt und da will ich dieses hier
nicht auf dem kuchen haben sondern unter
dem kochen
[Musik]
und hier vorne das ende dann einfach ein
bisschen verbinden
das ist dann der rückseite des kochens
ich glaube einen hefezopf google habe
ich echt noch nie gemacht auf einem
kanal also es wurde freiheit heute
jetzt nehme ich hier noch die restliche
butter und bestreicht das schön damit
und jetzt könnt ihr entweder den kuchen
also den teig noch einmal aufgehen
lassen und dann im heißen ofen backen
oder ihr stellt ihnen jetzt in der
kalten ofen schalte den ofen an und
durch das aufheizen geht dann eben auch
in der zeit der kuchen auf das heißt ihr
könnt beides machen und so weit ich das
jetzt machen ich stelle den kuchen jetzt
in den kalten backofen schalten an und
las ihnen dann schön fertig backen und
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr noch dampf stoß
schulvereins wählen wenn nicht lass das
einfach weg
[Musik]
den guglhupf habe ich jetzt bereits vor
etwa zehn minuten aus dem ofen geholt er
dürfte leicht abkühlen
jetzt kann ich hier oben weil hier oben
ein bisschen hibbelig aussieht das
rumpelige wegschneiden müsst ihr nicht
aber wenn ich ihnen jetzt stürzte dann
ist einfach schief deswegen schneidig
zweck und hier könnt ihr gerne das
messer einfach an der form ansetzen und
praktisch so ganz gerade wegschneiden
froh dass ich dann das ist die nation
jetzt vorsichtig heraus stürzen und
perfekter guglhupf den blick ich jetzt
noch ab und lasst den abkühlen und macht
dann noch eine klasse drauf wenn man mag
wenn nicht kann man doch so schön ist
mit kids so schnell
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt noch nicht so drauf
dafür verwende ich frischkäse butter
zucker zitronensaft und wandel extrakt
die zutaten kann ich hier einfach kurz
berühren
und dann kommt die glasur hier direkt
oben drauf aber wie gesagt könnt ihr den
kuchen auch gerne ohne klausur essen
[Musik]
oh mann ich wollte einfach nur von oben
runter tropfen lassen
jetzt habe ich einen komplett gestrichen
er sollte gar nicht so wieso habe ich
das jetzt gemacht
ich wollte nicht verstreichen
wisst ihr auch machen sind so in meiner
vorstellung weiter voll schön
sag mir bitte dass wir immer noch schön
ist er auch nicht zu lügen und diese
technik nennt sich die abstreift technik
der befragt so viel klasse
eigentlich wollte ich sie ursprünglich
runter tropfen lassen und war aber die
konsistenz nicht richtig also habe ich
jetzt komplett damit eingestrichen und
wieder so abgezogen und so finde ich
ganz schön mit sonderstreifen technik
also einfach mit dem pinsel von außen
nach innen so streichen
guckt mal
ja so wird und jetzt nämlich ein
bisschen spekulatius gewürz streit ist
hier noch so obendrauf
die zucker und bisschen und ordentlich
aus und hier oben ein wenn nur ein paar
walnüsse drauf und fertig dann darf
jemand kommen zum probieren vielleicht
morath vielleicht aber auch nicht
ich guck mal wer lust auf urlaub hat
[Musik]
produktplatzierung in meinem video immer
gespannt muss ehrlich sagen ich bin
völlig erkältet ich kann das nicht im
oktober schmeckt die konsistenz ja die
transistoren bisschen aber wir sind echt
gratis wenn wir schon auch die nase zu
google hat mit spekulatius feigen und
walnüssen und ich mag es nicht wenn
google ruft zu trocknet das gedacht okay
das kann aber egal ob erkältungen dass
ich es war vielleicht nicht der ist es
nicht trocken und das noch keine rosinen
drin nein wo ich hab's musik
ich weiß was ich aber ich lieb' hefezopf
mit rosinen für die rosinen im kuchen
ist der wird auch hundewelpen streiks im
plus könnte einmal durchzählen wie auf
der diese hunde werbung wird es schon
gebrannt
ich finde es ganz schlimm kein problem
aber da wir kurz darauf hört man wenn
man merkt schon dass ist ein weicher
kugler und richtig sei es auch noch so
jetzt probiere mal umsonst ist doch gut
wenn ich erkältet noch besser schmecken
aber das war ja und zwar hier ja
wirklich schmeckt aromatisch oder speck
schluss gar nicht mehr richtig schmeckt
aromatisch im natürlich echt sein dann
ist echt gut oder deine erkältung ist
nicht so schlimm der schnupfen
heute morgen machen auch ganz schlimm
ok also morath schmeckt der kuchen das
heißt er ist gut
probiert ihn gerne mal aus auf see ließ
- blog digits das rezept oder in der
kostenlosen app ihr könnt euch einfach
aussuchen
viel spaß beim nachbacken und bis zum
nächsten mal und wir machen noch fotos
vom anschnitt buch bevor wenn er nicht
fest
[Musik]